i confess on a comic relief no to
experiencing some joy when my least
favorite congressman adam schiff got
spanked in broad daylight on the view
finally being forced to answer for his
toxic role in promoting the totally
discredited phony trump russia dossier
that tortured then president trump and
put the country through hell utter hell
what shift squirm
through this tough line of questioning
from morgan ortegas you may have an
awesome
disinformation yourself for years by
promoting this i think that's what
republicans and what people who
entrusted you as the intel committee
chair are so confused about your
culpability in all of this well i
completely disagree with your premise
it's one thing to say allegations should
be investigated and they were it's
another to say that we should have
foreseen in advance that some people
were lying to christopher steele which
is impossible of course to do but but
let's not use that as a smoke screen
to somehow shield donald trump's
culpability
for
inviting russia to help them in the
election which they did none of that is
undercut none of that serious misconduct
is in any way diminished by the fact
that people lied to christopher steele
no i think just your credibility is
its credibility is non-existent this was
totally bs and it put the country judge
through agony and it it tortured him and
i think made him crazy it was awful it
made who crazy president trump no i
don't think it i
have made me crazy but i think he kind
of held it together right but here's but
he did hold it together
this guy's ship he's a sack of chef you
know
this is a guy who can say that slowly
sack of schiff this guy is constantly
running around saying i've got the
evidence i've got proof beyond a
reasonable doubt and even in his denial
he says we can't we can't shield trump
from inviting russia uh asking russia to
help him in the election i mean even it
when he's shown to be a liar that he
didn't have any evidence he didn't have
proof beyond a reasonable doubt he's not
willing to apologize for it we hated
each other in america families didn't
talk to each other about russia
collusion
for the first time and they're still
talking about it is that russia and not
china is the biggest enemy of the united
states at this point i i think he's a
pathetic individual and i don't believe
a word and i think to judges the judge's
point that th this led figure in the
chain remember the chain of events this
led i think directly to the first
impeachment this unsettled the republic
in a way that was very profound for what
the third time in american history this
is not a little thing that this this
punk did
schiff ruined many waters thanksgivings
because he made my mom
deranged and i'm serious this really
destroyed the country that's what trump
wanted to do over remember said if you
take away the hopes i should get a
do-over we now know that the democrats
started the hoax the democrats
paid for the dossier and now we know the
democrats put the lies in the dossier so
schiff comes out on the view of all
places and gets his teeth kicked in he's
been doing interviews the whole year and
now obviously he has to go to the view
where a guest host morgan ortegas holds
his feet to the fire that is so pathetic
that it took this long for the press to
ask him a straight up question
at this point we have to assume
everything the democrats say is
erroneous at this point we're going to
find out the election was rigged greg
i'm just waiting
it was that's a counter narrative
but dana there there was a suspension of
decency in the way the russia collusion
completely probe
was carried out and there was no fair
play for the president and i really
believe that william barr saved
the republic by sticking up for trump
and saying
they're going to make him nuts by by
continually attacking him for something
he totally denies and then and then when
the uh the mueller report came out
exonerating him essentially still there
were the thanksgiving days
even today i mean even after these
indictments and even after all that we
know about what's been happening with
the durham investigation the the
congressman goes on he's written a book
that's why he's on the view let's don't
forget he's written a book that's why
he's out i don't know i don't know
that's not let's not give him any more
promotion
but how i screwed the car so he wants to
promote a book he hasn't had to do a
tough interview in years because he
doesn't put himself in that position he
probably did not expect that from morgan
who had the right tone she also knows
what she's talking about and he's
basically said you can't believe what i
say but still actually you have to
believe everything that i say he reminds
me of the prosecutor in the written
house trial yeah i mean that it was
not dissimilar um
you know it's interesting that you say
that because
it it puts
it discredits our institutions so
profoundly
like in the you see a prosecutor lying
you see the the prosecutor in the in the
russia collusion case making crap up and
it kind of deflates you because these
were the building blocks of our republic
you know you have to if you can't trust
the state to prosecute honestly if you
can't trust the justice department to
investigate honestly i mean what well
the truth is coming out and you know the
wheels of justice turn slowly but also
it will be exposed i'm confident of that
and i think that if i were hillary
clinton on my next book i would not go
and try to sell it on the view if morgan
ortega is the guest host
but greg to your point about uh the the
uh the written house trial
and and our comments being so out of
sync with the majority
this russia collusion news is not
carried anywhere this is this is
probably the biggest point because as
much as i am repulsed by adam schiff
hold that thought i also want to say it
was great to see morgan ortega's on the
view it was like she seemed so out of
place with her pleasant serious tone
it's like seeing dana at an s m dungeon
it seems so weird but that's a visual
yeah but so okay so like i'm disgusted
by him but he didn't do this by himself
right right if you think about 2016 to
2020 the number of hoaxes that were
created by the democrats but engineered
really by the media you had the fine
people hoax you had the russian hoax the
drinking bleach hoax the white supremacy
movement hoax what what happened to that
all of these things the hooker's in the
hotel room yeah well that's a steel
dossier and that is the russian
collusion that's how it started so all
of these things did untold damage to so
many people
personal political institutions
the media intelligence republicans used
to be pro-fbi
doj pro cia no they are now as radical
as abby hoffman like we're all now on
the same side as glenn greenwald and
matt taibi because we all now saw what
they had seen years ago but
where are my questions where is the
legitimate reckoning for this five-year
hoax like what can you do because
clearly he's not gonna be voted out this
guy thinks he's still gonna run he said
he and by the way why does he keep
saying erection instead of insurrection
what's up with that who's chef pencil
neck so what about that
what about what jesse said about
families divided you know there's this
alternate realities now why are you
asking me that because you have kids
yeah i have kids but you know most of my
kids
are with me more regularly
yeah they're sensible look here here's
the bottom line we have never been torn
apart as a country as we were by this
russia collusion delusion they hurt all
of us and they and you know i had
friends for years who won't talk to me
because of donald trump as if he is a
putin puppet or a russian asset it's
really disgusting what they did they
divided it horrible i don't know
it's terrible